[Música]
en mexico los miles de migrantes que
hacen parte de la caravana esperan el
permiso para poder transitar por el país
mientras buscan llegar hasta eeuu este
documento fue producto de un acuerdo con
las autoridades mexicanas tenemos
reportes de nuestros enviados especiales
decenas de miles de personas marcharon
en eeuu para exigir un control sobre la
compra y el uso de armas unas 450
manifestaciones estaban convocadas para
el pasado sábado luego de una serie de
tiroteos que dejaron decenas de muertos
por todo el país
el gobierno de bolivia calificó como un
precedente histórico la condena de 10
años contra la ex presidenta interina
jeanine áñez la ex mandataria señaló que
es inocente y que seguirá por la vía
internacional analizamos en esta emisión
hola bienvenidos a las noticias de
américa en france 24 los saluda andrés
meza muñoz empezamos en mexico una
caravana con miles de viajeros
indocumentados avanza en dirección a
estados unidos los migrantes partieron
del sur del territorio donde muchos
esperan el permiso para transitar 30
días por el país luego de que la noche
de este viernes alcanzaran un acuerdo
con las autoridades mexicanas
previamente hablamos con nuestro enviado
especial a tapachula andrés suárez
jaramillo quien nos contó cómo será el
próximo recorrido
bueno esto es importante aclarar que hay
dos tipos de migrantes el migrante que
tiene dinero y que una vez recibido este
pase migratorio puede tomar un bus
directamente hasta la frontera norte de
méxico bordeando el estado de texas para
cruzar por dos puntos uno es piedras
negras y otro es acuña donde se presume
que el río bravo tiene un caudal bajo y
por allí pueden cruzar ilegalmente el
otro inmigrante es el que no tiene
dinero el que no tiene recursos y que
seguirá caminando rumbo hacia oaxaca o
conseguir dinero para tomar un bus hasta
la ciudad
para ello es posible que los 30 días que
tienen de permiso se le acaben así que
aspiran en la comarca es la comisión de
los refugiados de ayuda para los
refugiados tener un nuevo permiso una
visa humanitaria de un año y este sábado
en varias ciudades de eeuu miles de
manifestantes salieron a las calles para
presionar al congreso para que endurezca
las leyes de control de armas de fuego
en el país la comisión sigue viva en la
nación norteamericana tras una serie de
tiroteos que han dejado decenas de
muertos durante las últimas semanas
informe de jamal benomar
hosting washington y nueva york en eeuu
tras los recientes tiroteos que causaron
decenas de muertos miles de
manifestantes marcharon por un mayor
control de las armas de fuego
me da la esperanza de que tal vez se
puede hacer algo es difícil porque ya
hemos hecho esto antes y no hemos visto
ningún cambio pero no significa que
vayamos a dejar de luchar el 24 de mayo
un joven de 18 años asesinó a 19 niños y
a dos profesoras sin una escuela
primaria de uralde cerca de la frontera
con méxico unos días antes un
supremacista blanco también de 18 años
mató a 10 personas afrodescendientes en
búfalo en el noroeste del país
el presidente de byd él pidió a sus
conciudadanos que se mantuvieran
movilizados
demasiada gente está muriendo
innecesariamente y lo que se propone en
la cámara y en el senado es marginal
pero de todos modos la respuesta es
marcha vaivén también reiteró las
reformas que quiere del congreso como la
prohibición de los fusiles de asalto y
de los cargadores de alta capacidad y el
reforzamiento de los controles de
antecedentes psicológicos de los
compradores pero en un país en el que
casi uno de cada tres adultos posee al
menos un arma los conservadores se
oponen firmemente a cualquier medida que
en su opinión vulnera lo que llaman sus
derechos la cámara de representantes
votó el miércoles 8 de junio la
prohibición de la venta de rifles
semiautomáticos
a menores de 21 años pero esa medida no
tiene casi ninguna posibilidad de ser
aprobada en el senado donde se necesita
el apoyo de 10 conservadores en otras
noticias del continente el lugar
conocido como 'el chernóbil chileno
tiene a sus cercanos pobladores sumidos
en altos niveles de contaminación lo que
les ha ocasionado problemas de salud el
centro industrial tiene 4
termoeléctricas de carbón además de la
empresa codelco encargada de extraer el
8 por ciento del cobre andrés granadillo
nos cuenta más
intoxicados con gases desconocidos así
están más de 100 personas de quintero y
puchuncaví lugar conocido como 'el
chernóbil chileno un problema que se ha
repetido durante varios años no podemos
seguir teniendo
sin controlar una empresa empresas que
producen tóxicos sin tener una anomalía
en el país de qué estamos hablando si
esto pasa solamente en quintero
lo que algunos solamente están en
quinteros tenemos incluso en el
sacrificio donde él
el gobierno y el estado nos ha hecho
responsables en 2018 unas 600 personas
acudieron a centros médicos con un
cuadro clínico atípico de vómitos de
sangre dolores de cabeza mareos
parálisis de las extremidades sumado a
extremas ronchas en la piel que
sufrieron en particular niños toda mi
hija con suero su diagnóstico como te lo
acabo de mostrar
intoxicación por gas el desconocido y
volvemos al mismo cuento del 2018 y
volvemos el mismo cuento no tanto del
2018 sino del 2014 y de hace años atrás
esto es una seguidilla de episodios este
lunes tras detectar una concentración de
dióxido de azufre 5 veces superior a la
permitida las autoridades declararon la
emergencia ambiental suspendieron las
clases y prohibieron la actividad física
en este foco de contaminación el 4
termoeléctricas a carbón y refinerías de
crudo además está codelco la empresa
estatal chilena de cobre responsable del
8 por ciento de la oferta mundial la
mayoría de la población trabaja en las
industrias contaminantes por lo que no
quieren el cierre definitivo de las
fábricas sino exigen del gobierno un
mejor hospital que tenerlo en los
proyectos o trasladar a otros lugares la
fundición de codelco
el oficialismo en bolivia celebró la
condena de 10 años a la ex presidenta
interina ye nine años por los delitos de
incumplimiento de deberes y resoluciones
contrarias a la constitución años quien
asumió el poder tras la salida de evo
morales- después de las caóticas
elecciones de 2019 dijo que es inocente
y que volvería a asumir la presidencia
si tuviera la oportunidad previamente
hablamos con paula antonio coca abogado
consultor político y jurídico y docente
universitario y quien nos contó qué
puede pasar con el caso de la ex
mandataria en instancias internacionales
hay que tomar en cuenta lo siguiente ya
hay muchos informes sobre los hechos de
octubre y noviembre en bolivia entre
ellos su informe de la cdh que
estableció que la administración de
justicia y la justicia el tribunal
constitucional obraron mal al decir que
la constitución algunos articulados en
bolivia eran inconstitucionales porque
la reelección de evo morales en la
presidencia era un derecho humanos y tal
como lo se están escuchando queridos
amigos y amigas de todo el continente
punto 1.2 tanto el informe del grupo
interdisciplinario jay como del relator
de la organización de las naciones
unidas garcía sayán apuntaron de que hay
un abuso hacia años en lo que fue la
detención preventiva una figura que es
la excepción pero no la regla en bolivia
es al revés y segundo que la
administración de justicia en bolivia no
es imparcial no es independiente no hay
tal cosa y lo digo como abogado entonces
obviamente el gobierno puede decir esto
pero al final eso no impide que
cualquier persona que se ha vulnerado
sus derechos por un estado acuda a la
instancia internacional
naciones unidas- se sumó a la
preocupación por la situación del
periodista británico don phillips y el
ecologista brasileño bruno pereyra
desaparecidos desde el domingo 5 de
junio en una zona remota del amazonas'
la pareja que estaba trabajando sobre
los peligros que enfrenta la selva
amazónica había sido amenazada días
antes en un desarrollo de la
investigación brasileña que ha sido muy
criticada la policía local informó del
hallazgo de posibles restos humanos
en lo profundo de la selva amazónica la
búsqueda de un periodista británico y un
experto indígena brasileño ambos
desaparecidos está en marcha con philips
y bruno pereyra fueron vistos por última
vez el 5 de junio mientras viajaban por
el río y tacoa y las autoridades
brasileñas han encontrado posibles
restos humanos cerca de la ciudad de
atalaya do norte tras un lento inicio de
la investigación
este era uno de los grandes problemas
que tenía la gente desaparecieron y el
gobierno fue lento en responder en los
últimos días eso finalmente se ha
solucionado tras una enorme presión
pública principalmente de sus amigos
periodistas
y en todo el mundo la gente se está
preguntando dónde están dom y bruno
incluso también se han encontrado
rastros de sangre en un bote la policía
brasileña considera sospechoso al
propietario de la embarcación un
pescador tanto phillips como pereira son
experimentados especialistas en el
amazonas que estaban realizando un viaje
de reportaje en la zona antes de
desaparecer recibieron amenazas de
muerte por su trabajo en el valle de
javarí donde viven cazadores y
pescadores ilegales el valle de javarí
en el amazonas es el segundo territorio
indígena más grande de brasil instamos a
las autoridades brasileñas a redoblar
sus esfuerzos para encontrar a phillips
y pereira el tiempo es esencial en vista
de que hay un riesgo real para sus
derechos de la vida y la seguridad el
presidente brasileño y air bolsonaro ha
enfrentado presión de la prensa
internacional para reforzar la
investigación después de que se
informara de que la búsqueda no había
contado con suficientes recursos hasta
que este informativo gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]